where do the world's richest people
prefer to call home
despite some shifts within the rankings
the most popular locations are largely
the same as 2021.
these are the top 10 cities with the
most billionaires
in 10th place is seoul the south korean
capital is back on the list for the
first time since 2019. three of seoul's
four billionaire newcomers are self-made
dropping from the number eight spot san
francisco is home to four fewer
billionaires than last year the city
actually welcomed a stable of new
ultra-rich entrepreneurs but the
plunging fortunes of others left the
city with a net loss
in eighth place is mumbai the indian
metropolis held on to the number eight
spot with a net gain of three
billionaires compared to last year
including faguni nayar who became
india's richest self-made woman with an
estimated net worth of 4.5 billion
dollars after taking her beauty and
fashion retailer nika public in november
the city's richest resident reliance
industries chairman mukesh ambani
single-handedly makes up for more than
30 percent of the collective net worth
of mumbai's billionaires
taking the number seven spot is moscow
moscow lost more billionaires than any
other city on the list amid the fallout
from russia's invasion of ukraine all
but two living in russia's capital came
away worse off than they were a year
prior vladimir leezen the chairman of
steel products manufacturer nlmk group
and moscow's richest person shed about 8
billion of his personal wealth
26 others fell off the billionaire's
list altogether
a hub for self-made billionaires china's
silicon valley fell to number six after
losing nine billionaire residents over
the past year three were investors in
the vaping company s'more international
whose shares plummeted 64 as the chinese
government threatened to crack down on
electronic cigarettes shenzhen's richest
person
also took a hit the internet media
tycoon's fortune dropped by more than 28
billion dollars since 2021.
shanghai lost fewer billionaires than
other chinese cities but still saw its
stable of super-rich residents drop from
64 to 61. bucking the trend shanghai's
richest person liu yang jing the
chairman of agriculture and chemicals
firm east hope group more than doubled
his fortune to an estimated 13.2 billion
dollars
london rose to number four as it relaxed
long-standing pandemic restrictions
though it had a net gain of three new
billionaires the city actually welcomed
six new three comma club members
including the first bulgarian and
estonian citizens ever named
billionaires by forbes all of whom have
their primary residences in london
another city with a dramatic drop in
billionaires hong kong lost a dozen amid
a year of market to mult and strict
covet-19 protocols the stalling tourism
industry knocked casinos and hotel
billionaires from the city's super-rich
ranks
increased government scrutiny unleashed
a world of pain for the super-rich in
china's capital who have shed
174.3 billion dollars from their
collective net worth since 2021. a total
of 17 billionaires fell below the three
comma threshold a rare winner among the
turmoil was zhang yaming the founder of
tick tock owner bike dance and beijing's
richest resident who is 14.4 billion
dollars richer than last year a fresh
infusion of wealth and trouble in asia's
markets over the past year helped end
the short-lived reign of beijing which
usurped new york as the top billionaire
city for the first time in six years in
2021. new york gained eight new
billionaire residents over the past year
more than any other city on the list
most are in the finance industry
including thrive capital founder josh
kushner while other nyc newcomers
include the first nft billionaires
identified by forbes devin fisner and
alex attala the co-founders of the buzzy
blockchain startup open c despite the
heightened competition media magnate
michael bloomberg remains the richest
resident accounting for some 13 percent
of the city's total billionaire wealth
you